I want to talk to the text for a second
because the movie just looks and sounds
I'm so glad it was a print oh my god it
was just beautiful and it's got this
whole kind of like I mean I've been in
Chicago a few times but this Chicago is
just like stamp into your memory so talk
to me about about cutting movie together
and shooting it you know will speak to
the cinematographer first speak speaks
before it's like I already because you
guys have all these earnest holzman AFC
he's very hard sources under lighting
all the beautiful black skin and primary
colors brah what did you do talk to me
well Ted Knight first met at Nate's that
Natan Al's I think it was and we talked
about the movie and then when we get to
Chicago he showed me some books of
photographs they're all black and white
so I knew that we wanted that he wanted
to have a kind of a a monochromatic look
to the civil film and so I purposely you
know elected not use a lot of bright
colors in the lighting except for the
reggae scene and the the steppin scene
where we backlit with blue and then we
backlit with red in the in the in the
rigging and everything else was pretty
neutral and shot and Shaun's wardrobe
was pretty neutral and the walls were
pretty Rogers walls were pretty neutral
Sean Barden the Kombi and then briefly
when we were talking about Nina's
photography we discussed the possibility
of opening the film with some black and
white b-roll and so since I was there
during prep I just went out and and did
a lot of stuff with with a production
assistant myself which I really enjoyed
and and it made it into the movie which
was really great excellent excellent
and and I will just say one thing about
I just seeing the movie tonight was like
seeing you for the first yes it was and
I occasionally I look at something as a
oh I
haha yesterday bruh my fit my favorite
shot in the movie by the way Nia is your
close-up when you know lorenz gets the
call from Lisa that morning and your eye
opens I've always loved that close-up of
you and well let me just say quickly
just to add quickly onto that Ernie came
to me through Jeremiah Samuels we didn't
know each other but what impressed me
about Ernie was that he had we had a TV
background which I knew I was going to
need for it because the schedule was
very aggressive and he was he started
his career as Jordan Crona Webb's
assistant and so he was the AFI in turn
on Blade Runner and had assisted Jordan
for commercials and movies throughout
the 1980s and so I knew that okay well
we can fight there's a common language
there that we knew we could get to where
we wanted to you know get to in terms of
the lighting and what we had to do with
the photography and cast with all black
people all different range of skin tones
the things you have to keep in mind most
people don't recognize this is that you
go see a mainstream Hollywood movie in
the days prior to the DI
to the advent of the DI and all of the
white skin tones are pretty even they're
all pretty much the same or at least
that's how the Codex negative renders
them even though white people in real
life have different tones in the movies
they tend to get evened out and it's
pretty similar
whereas this whole range of skin tones
was going to be very challenging I don't
care about you know what I mean and so
anyway so right exactly so we had to so
Ernie and I had to work that part of it
out and figure out what we're going to
do but that's a end and I should say
finally the photography at the beginning
of the picture with the exception of one
shot is mine all of that black and white
is Ernie shot I have by the way test
dance you know wanting to shoot the film
on the slowest speed possible Ted wanted
really rich really fine grain so we shot
at a si a hundred and so you know just
add it to the challenge of the project
which I
embraced irony but my grandma would say
you are anointed breath because the skin
in this movie is just so good so the
only person up here who I've met before
this evening is Maisy hoy who edited
this film because and I would just speak
for like 30 seconds the editor of
moonlight join Macmillan Academy Award
nominee join Macmillan assisted Maisy or
like seven features before coming with
me to make moonlight so Maisy I've had
martinis with you I had no idea you cut
this movie talk to me about it you
probably didn't wait till the end of the
movie
I was probably making out when the
credits roll
that's why how did you and you come to
come to link up at theatres one and then
cut the film I'm not sure I think it was
neck wetzlar I think Chad Scott it was
Nick Nick's I didn't have anybody on my
list I didn't know what to do
Nick said Nick Wechsler had produced the
player that was directed by Robert
Altman she had cut the player had worked
in Bob's cutting room her whole career
started on McCabe and mrs. Miller and in
fact fun fact Maisy actually as a young
girl young woman plays one of the
Chinese prostitutes in McCabe and mrs.
Miller and has a nude scene in the hot
soap casually here set up a scene we
went up tonight 1900 editing a love zone
publican about tonight Alan finds that
car think of a need lands here fantastic
so the fact that she had worked for
Robert Altman caught my attention
because I knew that for the scenes with
the group I wanted to play with this
sort of overlapping dialogue that Altman
I kind of stole the technique from him I
was very influenced by mash and some of
the other pictures he had made exactly
so I needed somebody who technically
understood how to do that who had done
that for the guy who invented it so that
was a part of it the fact she was a
woman was a part of it as well because I
knew that okay it's a romantic thing and
I'm just me I don't want to be stuck
with a bunch of dudes in the cutting
room trying to figure out is this
working emotionally or not but I felt
she'd be helpful that way as well so now
you can get but that's how she came to
come together quickly to come together
that it take you time to find the film
because some of the match cut
is just extraordinary to talk to me
about in the Edit room how quickly did
it come together
well energy came came together quite
quickly because Ted knew what he wanted
you know and he shot two cameras so all
that overlapping dialogue was easy to
edit and when I was talking to Ted you
know I told him I said you know I'm not
afraid of cutting a movie where there's
overlapping dialogue because usually you
know when you're on on the set the sound
guy would say cup no overlapping
dialogue please and then you have to
invent it which doesn't feel natural at
all and so what I love about this movie
I mean honestly I haven't seen it in 20
years is that the the naturalness of
everybody you know and my favorite scene
is the cab ride and I'll tell you why
you know because I I go and I do seminar
you know teach at different schools and
I use that as an example of comedy
brilliant timing brilliant and and I
remember when we were getting notes from
the studio they wanted me to cut to Nina
and stay on her and I go and then when
we came back I said to Ted I said you
know I don't agree with that because it
really is about the reaction of Lisa you
know she sells it in and at the end you
go to Nina and it's what the biggest
laughs you know of the whole movie and I
didn't realize how funny the whole movie
was [ __ ] hilarious yes